hey everyone this is Steve Montreal with
collider and we're at the collider
supper Suite here at tiff with everyone
behind Aristotle and Dante I want to
start with congratulations on your movie
and being accepted in the Toronto
International Film Festival
um most of the people who have who are
watching this right now will actually
not have seen the movie yet I hate
asking the generic question but how have
you actually described the film and the
material to like your friends and family
oh I want to hear the boys answer this
question okay
good boy okay so uh we we meet Aristotle
at the very beginning he's a 15 year old
Mexican-American young man it's uh
summer 1997 in El Paso Texas and uh he
just lives in a constant state of like
unease and resentment towards himself
towards the world around him and um he's
just he wants to be left alone but then
uh one day at the pool he meets lovely
Mr Dante Quintana and uh you know all
the magic that Dante is and their
friendship that's just that's just the
Catalyst towards Ari's journey of
self-discovery and self-acceptance
that was pretty perfect
I have a question how many times did you
practice that in front of a mirror
that was awesome it's off the cuff you
know you make the movie you know it
sticks in your mind you know yeah I'm
totally teasing do you do you want to
add anything or is that that was pretty
yeah that was really lovely very good
yes
we'll just have mac do it every
interview all right
um talk a little bit about if you don't
mind what was it about this material
that resonated so strong with you that
you felt like I need to tell the story I
need you know because making a movie and
doing something like this is you know
it's a lot of time and energy yes it's a
lot of time energy it took seven years
to get here so this is a really exciting
moment for me and to be sharing it with
both of them
um when I read the book it just unlocked
something in me a Humanity a compassion
that I really wanted to bring to the
screen so I was gonna through hell or
high water I was gonna make it happen
and I'm really happy that people saw the
vision for it and came out and supported
and showed up with so much love because
that's really what that story was about
and is one of the reasons so happy
you're in studio and it's after the
Toronto Film Festival is
stories like this are they're tougher to
get made they're they're tough to you
know it's not like you're making a
Marvel movie here or like you know the
the normal romantic comedy if you will
um and so talk a little bit about the
challenges of of was it a was it like a
massive Boulder pushing up the hill or
was it like a smaller rock in terms of
getting people's you know uh opening
their checkbook and wanting to help tell
the story it was a massive Boulder that
took seven years that slowly kept
chipping away and I think that in the
seven years we like evolved as a society
where there was room for stories like
this and there was room for people like
me to tell these stories but like at the
beginning of the process I met with
producers that suggested like changing
the characters to be Chinese just so you
could access that kind of money which is
like not the story we were telling or
that I wanted to tell or a perspective
that I could speak on
um so it was I joke around a lot that
the latinx mafia showed up in order to
get this made which is like lin-manuel
Miranda
I think that they're sort of validating
the story and me had a lot to do with
like people opening up their checkbook
but that's what it takes it's people who
come before you to sort of like validate
a story and say it's important and
important to tell and that's what they
did I do feel myself uh just looking
from the outside that it has gotten
better in terms of rap representation
and more diverse storytelling I think
with streamers and just the last five
ten years it's really I feel like it's
changed uh for the better how do you
feel about it uh from your perspective I
think we have a long way to go but I
think that there's somewhat of a
willingness to start telling those
stories but there's still so much
resistant at the end of the day
Hollywood is built on fear and runs on
fear so taking a risk on a story that's
not hasn't been told before is scary for
people that like run Hollywood and the
movie making World
um that's why the stakes feel so high
for us in telling something like this
for the two of you um talk a little bit
about like obviously I'm sure you read a
number of scripts or you've seen
material whatever what was it about this
material for each of you that said I I
need to be a part of this and you know
what I mean yeah well when I first uh
when I first started getting involved in
this uh it was back in 2018 and I had
just done the uh the reading that we did
to promote the script and before that I
read the book and it was the only book
I've ever read that made me SOB my eyes
out it was so important to me and and
I resonated with both Ari and Dante so
much and I feel like so many people from
all different walks of life and so many
different communities can relate to them
in one way or another and it just felt
there was this like
magical Aura around it when I read it
what and it just it it stuck with me
so so deeply and it's unlike anything
I've ever read before
yeah and it was an immediate yes for me
as soon as I got to read the script
because it just seemed like a film that
that just radiated such strong like love
and empathy and warmth which I think is
what movies should be doing right now
definitely and I could imagine people
going to the theater and watching it and
taking a message to heart and then
walking out and saying like you know I
was supposed to come out of the house
and see this movie today I feel like
this is really going to stick with me
and I learned something from it
I would imagine when you are filming the
movie there is probably uh a day on set
a day during the shoot that you are
circling in the calendar like this is
going to be a really challenging day to
shoot to film emotionally I need to give
something that I don't know if I have it
in me whatever it may be for each of you
what was the the the night what was the
day that you were like circled on the
calendar in terms of oh this is going to
be a day
can we get into like
details about the story like yeah kind
of yeah okay so it's spoiling too much
okay well well the ending is very
emotional and that that is that is deep
most important part story what do you
think I think I mean yeah you know and
and it's that is just to to a t what the
story is about so I really wanted to get
that right and I was I was waiting to
film that it was it was a very even mix
of nervousness and excitement but um I
was definitely circling that day yeah I
have to agree with Max it was the same
day for me I mean that day we filmed
so many of just like some of the most
important scenes in the movie some of
the most pivotal and those are the
scenes that really hone in on the
message
that is coming across and so
yeah I um it was the same I had a lot of
nervousness but so much excitement and
just curiosity to see how all of it was
going to play out
it was every day for me we were on a
very limited budget with like limited
everything
um always limited time and I think
that's like across the board for any
director It's never enough
um but since the story was so
um nuanced I really wanted to like make
sure that I was making it worth my time
as far as like time management went
um but luckily everyone showed up so
game and willing that that made it so
much easier from the crew to the actors
um where I never really felt it it was
just like
fear that was never manifested into
something real I'm always curious about
the editing process because that's
ultimately where the movie comes
together
so so I am curious what did you learn
from like any friends and family
screenings that impacted the finished
film that I love a language film I love
movies that take their time but I think
that this movie
um required a different pacing so pacing
was a challenge for me as a Storyteller
that um I learned a lot from those
family screenings and just going through
the process for each of you what are you
actually most excited for people to see
in the movie
um if you don't mind answering the
question
go back
um definitely the representation the
Latin representation lgbtq
representation and um just portraying a
a modern day love story you know it's I
haven't seen too many new like romance
films you know and this is just pure
romance that's just gonna make the
audience Swoon so I'm excited to see
that
um I'm most excited for people to see a
story about the Latino Latina community
that is rooted in a compassionate
lens and gaze that I think there's a
strong void of that in many films about
our experience so I hope that through
that and the Heart of it that it's
accessible to not only like people from
my community But like everyone to maybe
unlock and understand something about us
that they don't necessarily do right now
yeah I'm I'm most excited for people to
just see a story that is that is
surrounded and rooted in love and
compassion and I feel like and a lot of
media that we see
um toxic relationships are a very key
plot point to move the plot forward or
you know the whole movie is about it and
in this movie every relationship with
with the parents and and with each other
and even Gina and Susie every
relationship just you know it it helps
everyone grow with each other there's a
lot of sequences in the pool and I'm
just curious are those days days that
you dread or days that you are like
because filming and water I mean like
people don't realize you're in there for
hours and hours and hours I think a lot
of story they both do yeah
well luckily they the the pool was
heated so it was actually really it was
it was like it was like Luke one
lukewarm water which is better than cold
um but so say you know what some days it
was it was easier than others some days
I was really excited to get in the water
but I remember the first the the first
shoot that we had in the water was
um
it was
a little challenging yeah it was a
little cold I get really cold easily I
don't have a lot of meat on these bones
so yeah we had like heaters on the side
of the pool to make sure that they were
warmed up every time that they came out
but luckily I didn't have to be in the
water so yeah I know at one point he's
like do I really have to get back in
there yeah if it became a little
torturous after a while but it was worth
it totally worth it yeah I'm so curious
um and I don't know how the casting
process went I don't know when you two
first met each other for you know what I
mean but what was it like the night
before you're going in for that final or
the chemistry read or the you know what
I mean like when you're really close to
getting a roll and you know you have
like one more meeting to do and it's the
next day like how much were you in your
head I mean I don't know how that all
went so you know
I actually have a story about this so
um I was feeling very nervous I was
feeling a lot of different emotions
um and when I do that I have like an
electric keyboard out in my backyard and
so I just I play that because it helps
calm me down and so
I was feeling all of these nerves and I
just decided I just need to calm down
and breathe and so I was playing
and there's telephone wires that go
across my back wall
and when I finished playing
I heard a little who
and I looked up and there was an owl and
it was it was just staring at me and it
just it did not break eye contact and
when I stared at it like all of the
nerves all of it it was animatronics
oh completely and I just felt this calm
that I had never felt before and I just
knew that everything was going to be
okay no matter what happened did you did
you think you were going to get the role
I honestly just answer it honestly
I um I had a feeling that I might
um
but I wasn't really thinking about that
too much I was just thinking about doing
the best that I could and being
as honest as possible and honoring the
character as much as possible
so you asked about the night before like
the last chemistry read so everything
moves so fast right in in casting and
all this stuff I live in Austin Texas
born and raised there I had never been
to La before I got an email it says hey
tomorrow we'd like to see you in La for
a chemistry oh my gosh all right so yeah
my mom and I packed our bags and then
yeah it was all we come we come back
home the next morning I wake up to a
phone call from U of L so we like to
offer the role of ourselves yes but yeah
that was crazy because it moves super
fast but um and I was I was a little
confident that I got the role you know I
was so as an Act of Faith I had to call
the grocery store I was working at and
quit but uh
you quit the grocery store because of
the movie yes oh my gosh yeah I needed
to have time to prepare for the rule
uh that's
awesome stories but it doesn't always
happen that fast no it's not like you
got
um uh so one of the things that um uh
we're doing for the people that are
coming into our Tiff studio is sort of
get to know your Tiff attendee
um and so I'm gonna ask you a few quick
questions I probably promise you this is
like harmless stuff but um here we go uh
uh what team for you what TV show would
you love to guest write and direct and
for each of you what TV show would you
love to guest star on
there's this HBO show called Veneno I
don't know if you've all seen it but you
should I would love to have you there
conceptualize that write that or guess
right on that it's if no if you haven't
watched it you should watch it
but yeah marvelous Mrs maisel I've oh
every time I watch that show I'm just
like God I would love to be on this I
mean not just the acting in that show
and the the writing is incredible but
the the set design and the the color
palette the costume design all I love
that show so much and yeah like hands
down that's my answer
I would say the bear on Hulu oh I'm
dynaw I love that show man I'd love to
be on it everybody seems like they have
such a good time and it's so fun to
watch it's super well made too yeah
that's what I keep hearing big fan uh I
agree and the bear is fantastic if you
haven't seen it I haven't seen the show
that I had
um what movie have you seen the most oh
that's such a good question Interstellar
no I love that movie that's probably my
favorite movie of all time really yeah
because well because of the the physics
in it is just so accurate sure no no I'm
not I'm I'm always fascinated by I'm
just of Nolan's filmography it's
interesting because a lot of people say
Prestige or you know uh but yeah I'm not
knocking it no no that reaction
I've asked this question to a lot of
different people and with Nolan movies
it's usually a different Choice yeah but
they're respecting the choice oh 100
whatever is your favorite is your
favorite yeah that's it mine is Leon the
Professional
so much that I got a tattoo
it's definitely on tattoo wow yeah that
is actually a [ __ ] really cool tattoo
and I totally know who it is yes
that's great I like I like the fact that
the um if we look at the tattoo that you
you just see the sunglasses without like
the you know what I mean choices yes Eve
yeah no totally The Matrix trilogy
I'm the biggest Matrix fan in the world
so what did you think about the new one
I liked it a lot I enjoyed it yeah I I
enjoyed the betterness of it yes that
was awesome I could keep going on but
anyway is there anything that you
collect or obsess over
oh
I'm a big physical media guy the Blu-ray
CDs stuff like that and the guitars too
right like music yeah yeah guitar gear
things like that I don't really collect
things but
um I love music and I love musical
instruments and so I like I don't I
don't like to spend a lot of my money on
stuff like usually when I go shopping or
whatever like I go to thrift shops
because I just but
I like minced instruments yeah I'll go
all out for musical instruments so
that's where you're not cheap yeah right
yeah that's where the money is there's
always one thing that I'm not cheap for
and it's that
wait I'm not I love eating I don't have
um time to collect anything which is
like you you're making me self-reflect
in like a real way I need more joy in my
life you need to like start collecting
[ __ ] well no some people also
um like I what another thing is like if
you ever go on eBay or Amazon like
what's the thing you're always looking
at you know but it's fun
um what do you wish more people knew
about making a movie
how long it takes
and how it's like you have an idea but
it's a long process to get there
um often and I think there again there's
never enough money
doesn't matter what level you work at
what kind of director you are it's never
enough yeah I've heard that from every
filmmaker including filmmakers that have
made 250 million dollar movies yeah it's
just never and that's like part of the
freedom of like oh there's no arrival at
anything like there's never this is
enough I've made it you know it's always
a Hustle uh the sacrifices that people
have to make you know there's so many
there were so many scenes that we filmed
in the movie that didn't that didn't
make it in because you know either
pacing or or the message or or whatever
um and it's it's tough you know it's
it's never going the vision is never
going to come out exactly the way that
you wanted or expected it to and
sometimes it's a good thing sometimes it
comes out better than expected but you
know sometimes there's always
there's a movie right the movie you make
and then the movie you edit yeah it's
always three different movies it's true
yeah I would say how much love and care
goes into it by everybody involved you
know and I feel like whenever like also
sometimes I'll see like a really bad
review for a movie online and it kind of
hurts my feelings like for people
involved because it's like they put all
their life force into that you know now
you're like calling it garbage and stuff
so I'd like everybody to know how much
hard work and soul everybody puts in the
movies I say that to people all the time
that no one sets out to make a bad movie
everyone is there to give it their heart
and soul well most people are and um you
know except for certain people I get
paid a bunch of money to be there
what TV show have you watched all the
way through more than once
um hard hitting question well okay I'm
just supposed to be fun by the way I
know yeah this is a good question so
I'll have two answers So True Detective
season one it's an anthology so I'll say
that I've seen that season so many times
I love it and then when I was little I
was young so it's way back when Netflix
was on the Wii I think I watched avatar
Last Airbender like four times in a row
no way my parents would be like this
show again okay
I'm a little basic so Breaking Bad
um obviously for obvious reasons I've
watched that um about three times over
um also the show called The Midnight
gospel on Netflix
um
yeah it's kind of it's animated by a
Pendleton Ward who animated and made
Adventure Time
um but it's kind of like it's like it
has like kind of a like a podcast feel
to it but they just animate around the
podcast and it's beautiful it's there's
it's so colorful and psychedelic it's I
love that show
um I'm basically out of time but uh just
a little bit my last thing for you about
the film
um one of the things that I I thought
that the film does so well is it talks
about the Journey of self-discovery and
um uh an acceptance of who you are and
can you sort of talk about like that
aspect and the fact that I think a lot
of people could end up seeing this movie
and feel their own story do you know
what I mean yeah of course it is my own
story I like to say that I thought I was
always a Dante but in reality I was
always an RA because I was missing the
love around me and I think it required
me to sort of like stand up and see
myself and be and walk through that in
order to one direct this story but also
tell it authentically so people could
find themselves in it and like that's
really what this is it's like there's
always people there ready to love you as
soon as you're ready to love yourself
and allow that love in I don't know if
you want to I um I when I actually first
played Dante I told H this but I felt
like Ari at that time I was 16 years old
I had no idea who I was and so
throughout the the three and a half
years that I had to to grow and change I
feel like by the time we actually filmed
the movie was the first time where I
really truly felt like
I've always I've always been a Dante
inside and I've always had that just
yearning to express myself as fully as
possible and so yeah my my journey with
this film really felt like I
transitioned from being someone like Ari
to someone like Dante
it was nice
yeah and we're all deserving to to to
allow and accept and embrace the love in
our lives and a lot of us short
ourselves of that so I hope the people
come see the movie and they walk out
feeling motivated to go on a similar
journey of self-acceptance and
self-discovery so they can really truly
be happy
on that note I'm just gonna say thank
you so much for stopping by our studio
and I really hope it this film is um
widely seen and you know what I mean I
wish you guys nothing but the best
um on that note thank you so much thank
you thank you